[Music]
al-shishani is a true superstar chef in
his native israel and a regular judge on
the country's version of MasterChef he's
turned his casual pita restaurant MS nan
into a global phenomenon with locations
in Tel Aviv Paris Vienna Melbourne and -
in New York City in April Shani opened
up a second location of his high-end
eatery hustle on here in the city as
well after the restaurant revolutionized
the dining scene in Tel Aviv I sat down
with him to get a taste of the
self-taught cooks fascinating approach
to dining this restaurant is based on
the same one you have in Tel Aviv yes
where did the idea come from for that
first restaurant there was no idea I
have no idea I have no concepts I ain't
concept because concept is to look for
me Bob and to try to find a system that
will succeed it's a kind of manipulation
I don't like it is that philosophy which
might help explain the transformation of
al Chinese restaurant Casa lon over the
course of an evening when somebody comes
in here to dine
what are you hoping they experience or
what I hope a very specific thing that
their life will be changed forever
from a meal form a meal it's not logic
to believe in that but I cannot stop
believing the early seating has the
trappings of a traditional restaurant
but the late seating morphs into this a
[Applause]
feast for all the senses SHINee brought
the Jamboree with him from tel-aviv but
after years of shaking up the restaurant
scene in his homeland SHINee says he was
looking for new sources of inspiration I
came to New York
because I saw and I understood everybody
that is living in the world is dreaming
about that city it's a huge thing Johnny
started with Israeli Street food Burley
last year he opened Miz nan in New
York's Chelsea Market SHINee says the
pita is one of the best translators of a
cities atmosphere I mean I could take
the main elements of the city and to
unselect them into a food that till the
end entering into a betta
when I first came to myself so I stood
that I have to make a new birth
therefore Dead Sea Johnny Sears his
brother on one side with chief he then
folds it which traps the steam and
crisps the cheddar finally the burger is
put inside a pita with aioli sour cream
peppers tomato and pickles I'm making a
fool of myself eating this because
that's how good it is oh this way
so we should shut down the cumin wasn't
enough and we should be better my
co-hosts are going to hate me because
they don't forget Miz non is also known
for breathing life into a veggie long
thought of as bland the roasted
cauliflower how many flowers do we have
in one molecule ten one that is the
flower and that is the leaves around the
seeds so in all the Eastham of the
gastronomy
[ __ ] used to break when the student
flower I decided not to break the flower
you should feel this right so it's the
old flower for you
you are in snow to break its it melts in
your mouth
yeah Sonny's secret actually believing
that each ingredient is a living
creature with its own will and then
developing an almost metaphysical
connection to the question his tomato is
a tomato the answer will always be no
it's not a tomato it's something else if
it's something is what it is that is the
journey what is a tomato what is an
Heywood why they are different what does
the world butter with tomato seeds it's
the best composition in the world
Shanny doesn't just bring his own take
on the food and atmosphere in his
restaurants you see his philosophy and
how they're run take hostel on which is
only open three nights a week how can
that even work as a business model it's
a 1 million dollar question Johnny says
most businesses only make money a few
days a week anyway and after three
nights that go into the wee hours he and
the staff have nothing left to give
it's almost impossible is to be a
miracle and that America has to be on
each piece to do it
seven days or six days and to be real
authentic to your creation it's a big
life you cannot do it you have to
refresh your soul before you are doing
it you have to be starved to do it it
almost seems as if al Shani wants to
feed your soul with each bite I can
change your life I can change one moment
experience this way of life and in the
end people are climbing the table I want
to go oh yeah I love this man and he
just has good with philosophy forever
mysterious of Isis he allows the food to
speak for itself instead of trying to
take over you can't always make a tomato
the same way you have to feel what that
tomato wants to be if I understood him
correctly at least I I think we don't
hate you because you had the burger
looking so good we hate that you have
that experience we're all going trust
that burger burger is I have a single
date in mind